frankie multus gets the fifth start of
the season for the athletics the first
against the dodgers they'd love to see
him have an outstanding performance
here's justin turner who's four for 11.
he got it
kept it away and that's the first
strikeout of the night for the frankfurt
montage two way and that'll bring up
cody bellinger
swung out of miss down he goes so a good
first inning for frankie montage 23 year
old out of justin texas starting his
third year with major league time dustin
may here's mitch moreland first and
second one away here's another 2-2
and he gets marling swinging with that
cutter
up to matt chapman with two out
former all-star third baseman who shoots
the first pitch that he sees to the
second baseman chris taylor and dustin
may escapes any trouble bases are loaded
with one out mckinstry gets ready to bet
slide to left
center kemp coming on making the catch
muncie heads for the play throw goes to
third
and the dodgers have the game's first
run zach mckinstry with an rbi sac fly
bases loaded one out nine
pole hitter
that's enough they've got a one-nothing
lead and they've got mookie betts up
there with taylor at second and rios at
first in the 2-2
it's a ground ball to third that's off
the goal forever chapman
dodgers getting a break
to load the bases up and keep this
inning going
a two-time platinum glove winner
this is a rarity you will not see that
very often
loaded for seeger
swings away line drive to center back
goes canna over his head
and short hops the wall
two runs are in mookie chugging for the
plate seeger's unloading the bases
they promptly take advantage of the
sloppy defense and lead it four nothing
corey seeger is so hot he could melt
metal and there's a lot of territory out
there in oakland that would have been
out of a lot of places where the gap
comes in a little closer
the catcher sean murphy
taken for strike three perhaps murphy
waiting for something else and he took
it right down broadway
second k for dustin to i tom the rookie
tom fouls 100 into the glove
back-to-back strikeouts to open the
second for may
yank down the line towards the corner
will smith off the foul pole
his second home run in his many games
and the dodgers lead 5-0
this one's a hanging split to a righty
and will smith grabs it before it gets
too far inside
and that hits taylor
is going to hold the elbow does not look
like there's a pad on that yeah
i think he just
his arm went numb
zach mckinstry the batter with two down
and two on one toss deals 02.
mckinstry but the line drive base hit to
beat the shift
muncie heads home the throw goes to
third and they lead six nothing
taylor back to the bag safely
second and third for bets in the dirt
pass murphy here comes taylor he'll
score standing up
leading by a touchdown and an extra
point
two and two thirds innings tonight for
frankie montos
and seeger against puck
three two bets takes off
so puck comes back gets the strikeout
and the inning comes to an end and they
have made
a change aj pollock comes in and left
and zach mckenzie moves to second so
chris taylor does leave the game after
getting hit on the elbow
breaking ball lifted to deep right field
bets going back onto the truck to catch
it just shy of the wall
gave it a ride but bets was there
one ball and two strikes
swing and a miss
olson down on strikes the fourth for may
facing mitch moreland who struck out his
first time they on his 50th pitch of the
night gets moreland
back foot cutter 11 pitch third for may
who leads it seven nothing now the bases
are loaded now rios
so puck gets the strikeout finishes off
edwin rios something to cheer about
dustin made with all kinds of support
tonight seven nothing he's
swinging and a miss filthy two-seamer
one away in the fourth on may's six
strikeout
here's kai tom
chomps one to first for max muncie for
edwin rios who will take it to the bag
and that is seven in a row retired
dustin may
with seven strikeouts in the game one
more will tie his career high
2-2
8-k for dustin may matching a career
high
and olson lost his bed in the process
the old saying get him early
really came true tonight with oakland
and dustin may because early on looked
like he could be on the ropes a little
bit as far as finding the strike zone
and oakland could have capitalized but
he has been way on his game now zach
mckinstry's had a good night
bounced up the middle and under the
glove
and the score is pollock
it's eight nothing
and assuming mckinsey gets credit for a
base hit they're gonna be his third
will face justin turner here in the
eighth
turner lifts this one into deep center
field back goes canal running on a room
it's gone
turner's first of the season makes it
nine nothing down jews
jt needed something to feel good about
looks like romo was trying to back for a
little sinker back there didn't slide it
off the edge of the plate and jt made
him pay here's canada leading off
against david price
went very high to left field
going back and
that baby's gone
for market first home run of the year
he's actually gotten off to a pretty
good start
open up the season
and the ends have runners at first and
third and chapman's coming up
chapman is going to beat it out it's a
hit and it's an rbi so matt chapman just
cute it
but you could tell
once it rolled past the pitcher
chapman's got that great speed it was
going to work 9-2
and here's kai tom time for his first
big league hit
center field and it's going to drop in
for a hit
it's gonna be an rbi and
tom has a big league batting average
his girlfriend's had that
telephone camera working every time he's
been to the plate this time
she's got the the video plus she's
clapping and cheering so
that's that's great
justin turner one for five with a solo
homer
turner able to get his bat on that up
the middle andrews got his glove on it
but that's all he can say mckinstry's in
they've got double digits 10-3 bellinger
at the plate here's the one-two
chopping the backs up olson race to the
bad collision
he's out
[Music]
[Applause]
looked like bellinger
got to the bag first
certainly by replay he did
and it may have
gotten spiked on the outside of the left
ankle don't know if it's where he was
spiked or if it just happened to turn
he came down on the bag with his left
foot to begin with
and
this play on the on the
replay is going to be overturned
yeah it wasn't even close no
ballinger beat that out and he beat it
out because he hustled
immediately miller's going to be taken
out of the game and he's holding a
he just rubbed a high left ankle area
oakland down to their final out
bouncing ball straight away short cory
seeger the winning streak is four and a
convincing one to open this series in
oakland by a final of 10 to three